hi I'm Ria today I'm going to show you
how to make store ball cake fancy but
easy way it says happy birthday on top
but today is not my birthday so I'm
going to make it a little bit prettier
I'm going to use of spatula remove all
the colorful icing anything that have
flat surface walks I'm going to dip my
obsessed spatula into hot water the
buttercream made with butter so when you
use hot spatula it will kind of melt it
looks a little bare so let's make it
more fancy I'm going to use edible
flowers you can hide imperfection using
flour nice so cake it's ready to make
klinka it's dip your knife in hot water
wipe it clean cut I love how it looks
it's so colorful upcycle bouquet cake
very fancy